you know so many of us out here who are
still kind of searching for the one look
at you - as relationshipgoals
cierra tell us what you prayed for
please we need the specific prayer what
you're crazy I will tell you I did
prayed and I prayed a good prayer and I
was focused in my prayer and I was
specific in my rare prayer has been a
big part of Ciara and Russell Wilson's
relationship more than we ever knew you
and Russell are doing a beautiful thing
with the abstinence thing in it and no
Sierra gets real about that choice in
the new issue of InStyle admitting that
the couples pact to stay celibate before
their 2016 wedding was a tough one to
keep quote that took a lot of Prayer it
was hard I can't lie still the level up
singer admits their relationship was
always easy saying they both knew they
were each other's one from day one it's
a sentiment Russell has shared with et
over and over again over the years she's
good as it gets
she's got such a kind heart she's
music's unbelievable just being around
of her energy who she is as a person and
she's a tremendous person tremendous mom
I love that about her best friend and
then madly in love with each other
obviously but that's cool you know we're
the Wilsons now so it's pretty cool just
to be able to have the woman they've
always wanted and then that's hurt the
person that has the biggest heart in the
world you know and like I said she's
amazing mom amazing person
[Music]